E
ROE VS. WADE OPINION.
>> SO MUCH FOR RESPECTING
AMERICA'S INSTITUTION JOINING US
IS THE AUTHOR OF THE PRICE OF
PRINCIPAL.
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALAN
DERSHOWITZ ALONG WITH FOX NEWS
LEGAL ANALYST GREGG JARRETT.
GREGUS, LET ME START WITH YOU.
WHEN WE HEAR ABOUT MY BACKGROUND
WHICH IS WOMEN'S RIGHTS AND EVEN
ABORTION RIGHTS FOR A OF TIME.
THE FACT THAT THE SUPREME COURT
EFFECTIVELY RETURNED DEMOCRACY
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SO THEY
CAN VOTE ON THESE THINGS
REMOVING IT OUT OF THAT CATEGORY
OF A COURT OF LAWYERS MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT THESE THINGS.
HOW IS IT THEY ARE ARGUING THAT
IT'S A STRIKE AGAINST DEMOCRACY
WHEN THE COURT WAS PRETTY MUCH
REMOVING IT FROM THEIR
JURISDICTION TO THE JURISDICTION
OF THE VOTERS THEMSELVES?
>> THE SUPREME COURT REPRESENTS
THE SANITY AND COMMON SENSE RULE
ORDER, IF YOU WILL.
JOE BIDEN, WHENEVER HE WEIGHS IN
ON THE CONSTITUTION, THE SUPREME
COURT, OR THE RULE OF LAW HE
MANGLES THE SUBJECT MATTER WHICH
ONLY UNDERSCORES THAT THIS GUY
GOT KICKED OUT OF LAW SCHOOL.
WHAT BIDEN KNOWS ABOUT THE LAW
CAN BE WRITTEN ON THE YELLOW
POST-IT.
I AM TALKING ABOUT THE LITTLE
ONE.
HIS LATEST THING IS LET'S
FEDERALIZE ABORTION-RIGHTS.
THAT'S A FOOLS ERRAND FOR TWO
REASONS FROM A LEGAL STANDPOINT.
REMEMBER WHAT THE SUPREME COURT
SAID.
THEY SAID WE ARE RETURNING THE
DECISION-MAKING TO THE STATE.
IF CONGRESS WOULD TRY TO CODIFY
IT, IT WOULD IMMEDIATELY BE MET
WITH A LAWSUIT TO STRIKE IT DOWN
USURPING THE POWER OF THE STATE.
FROM A PRACTICAL STANDPOINT, JOE
BIDEN WANTS TO CREATE THIS
CHRONIC STREET OF WHIPLASH EVERY
TIME A NEW PARTY TAKES OVER
CONGRESS AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY WOULD REVERSE THE PREVIOUS
DECISION ON ABORTION.
YOU WOULD HAVE THIS PERSISTENT
PING-PONG EFFECT.
ABORTION IS IMPORTANT.
IT SHOULDN'T BE TREATED LIKE A
RUBBER BAND EXPANDED AND
CONTRACTED.
>> THANK YOU, GREG.
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ, REGARDLESS
OF WHAT WE THINK OF THE
DECISION, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ON FOREIGN SOIL IS
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE SUPREME
COURT.
DO YOU FIND THAT TROUBLING?
>> I DO.
I FIND THE WHOLE ATTACK ON THE
SUPREME COURT INTEGRITY AND THE
SUPREME COURT'S TROUBLING.
I'VE BEEN STUDYING THE SUPREME
COURT AND THE CONSTITUTION FOR
60 YEARS.
I'VE SEEN IT GO THROUGH CYCLES.
IT SWINGS WIDELY.
I REMEMBER WHEN THE BIRCH
SOCIETY HAD SIGNS UP TO IMPEACH
EARL WARREN AND BILL DOUGLAS.
WHEN THE RIGHT WAS UPSET AT THE
LEFT SWING OF THE SUPREME COURT.
NOW THE LEFT IS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE RIGHT SWING OF THE SUPREME
COURT.
WE HAVE TO RESPECT THE
INSTITUTION.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THESE
JUSTICES STAND FOR THE RULE OF
LAW.
WE MAY CRITICIZE THE DECISIONS.
THAT IS FINE.
WHEN MY FORMER COLLEAGUE BRUCE
WARREN TRASHES THE SUPREME COURT
AS AN INSTITUTION, THAT WILL DO
TREMENDOUS DAMAGE.
THIS COUNTRY WILL COME BACK TO
HURT HER AND HER LIBERALS.
TODAY THE ATTACK COMES FROM THE
LEFT.
TOMORROW IT MIGHT COME FROM THE
RIGHT.
THOSE OF US WHO LOVE THE RULE OF
LAW, A RULE THAT WE CELEBRATE ON
JULY 4TH, HAVE TO STAND BY OUR
INSTITUTIONS AS INSTITUTIONS.
YES, CRITICIZE A PARTICULAR
DECISION AND TRY TO DO BETTER
NEXT TIME.
YES, THINK ABOUT WHETHER YOU CAN
DO LEGISLATION.
BUT DON'T TRASH THE COURT AS AN
INSTITUTION.
DON'T DO WHAT MY OTHER FORMER
COLLEAGUE SAID, PACK THE COURT.
LET THE DEMOCRATS IN.
SOON THE SUPREME COURT WILL SIT
IN YANKEE STADIUM WITH 30,000
JUSTICES DECIDING THESE CASES.
NINE IS THE RIGHT NUMBER.
LET'S KEEP THE SUPREME COURT AS
IT IS.
DON'T TINKER WITH JUSTICE.
>> ISN'T THE ANSWER, I DON'T
KNOW WHY THE LEFT SUDDENLY ONCE
THESE UNELECTED LAWYERS TO BE
MAKING ALL OF OUR DECISIONS.
ISN'T THE ANSWER TO HAVE
CONGRESS BE INVOLVED TO HAVE THE
STATE HOUSES BE INVOLVED?
ISN'T THIS THE NORMAL ORDER?
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THEY ARE MAKING
A REVERSAL OUT OF THIS EFFORT TO
PROTECT POLITICIANS FROM HAVING
TO MAKE DECISIONS ON THESE
ISSUES.
>> THAT WAS THE POINT OF
YESTERDAY'S SUPREME COURT
DECISION ON THE EPA.
THE SUPREME COURT WAS SAYING
READ THE DARN LAW.
NOWHERE IN THE CLEAN AIR ACT,
SECTION 111, DOES IT GIVE THE
EPA THIS UNBRIDLED POWER TO
REMAKE AN ENTIRE INDUSTRY WITH
PUNITIVE DRACONIAN MEASURES
AGAINST COAL-FIRED PLANTS AND
NATURAL GAS PLANTS.
THE SUPREME COURT IS SAYING READ
THE CONSTITUTION, READ THE
STATUTORY LAW, DON'T READ THINGS
INTO THEM.
BUT LIMIT YOURSELF TO WHAT THE
LAW SAYS.
>> AND THAT THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO MAKE LEGISLATION.
THAT'S THE JOB.
>> TURNED TO THE PUBLIC.
WIN ELECTIONS.
I'M A LIBERAL DEMOCRAT.
I WANT TO SEE US WIN MORE
ELECTIONS.
I WANT TO SEE YOU LOSE IN THE